breaking news as predicted by people
connected to reality but denied by
trumpets it seems Donald Trump jr. is
now expecting to be indicted and quote
soon two days ago
Gabriel Sherman reported in Vanity Fair
that people at the White House are quote
very worried about Donald Trump jr.
Politico has now broken the news that
Donald Trump jr. has been privately
telling his own friends that he believes
he could be indicted and the big area of
I guess we would call it interest or
what would the subject-matter of the
indictment be it looks like it could be
related to the fact that Donald Trump
jr. testified that he never under oath
that he never spoke to his father Donald
Trump about that infamous Trump Tower
meeting where Russians promised dirt on
Hillary Clinton did he lie about that if
he did that's bad not only for Trump jr.
but it's also very bad for Trump's
senior as well and that could explain
the rush to fire Attorney General Jeff
Sessions and to put in place an interim
replacement who is very hostile to the
Trump Russia investigation because if
Trump jr. lied about not having spoken
to Trump senior about the meeting in
advance that means Trump senior knew
about the meeting in advance which
immediately implicates Donald Trump in
potentially more crimes and the Gabriel
Sherman article says that the White
House insiders are worried that Moeller
would indeed be able to prove prove that
Donald Trump jr. committed perjury and
with perjury very often being so
difficult to prove this would be
absolutely massive and then we've got to
get to the meat of it if indeed Donald
Trump jr. lied under oath why did he do
it he obviously had an attorney with him
I'm sure that Don juniors attorney said
to him you're going to be under oath
it's dangerous legally speaking to lie
to federal investigators while under
oath it is a crime to do that and if
it's true as they claim that the Trump
Tower meeting with
Russians didn't actually produce
anything of value to use against Hillary
Clinton why would Don Jr feel the need
to lie about it at all except if the
meeting did have follow-up and Don jr.
had told his father the reason he would
lie is that he'd be making the call he'd
rather chance lying to investigators
then admitting that yes his father was a
knowing part of the effort to conspire
with a foreign country for the purposes
of winning an American election which
exposes them to all kinds of criminal
charges and just a reminder you remember
this Pat remember when Steve Bannon said
about Don Jr a year ago or so I think it
was Jan late December January when Steve
bannon's book came out quote they're
going to crack Don Jr like an egg on
national TV this may be the beginning of
trouble for Don Jr and correct me if I'm
wrong Pat you've been saying Don Jr is
one of the top and IT possibilities for
a while oh yeah I'm not alone in saying
that too I think this would be an
absolute bombshell if Donald Trump jr.
was to be indicted and then who knows
what would happen from there I think
Trump would be in a position where he'd
have to pardon his own son maybe even
fire Robert Miller and the investigation
and we have a constitutional crisis on
our hands I don't think he'd be so
willing to do that for people like Paul
Manafort for Michael Flynn for Michael
Cohen but his own son I think he would
pulled all the plugs pull out all the
stops and make sure that his son's not
gonna be locked up Don jr. he was
basically a waterboy he had nothing to
do with the campaign he had and has
nothing to do with the President of the
United States Donald Trump at all my
prediction is Trump won't literally say
he doesn't really think Don jr. was a
key part of the campaign that would
obviously be silly but I actually do
think that Trump is going to throw Don
Jr under the bus to some degree and the
reason why I think that is that we've
already learned that when the initial
news of the Trump Tower meeting first
broke we learned that Trump was
reportedly absolutely furious with Don
jr. and nothing had even really happened
then like
didn't know at that point how big that
meeting and the circumstances that led
up to it we're going to become so grab
the popcorn this is going to get
extraordinary very very soon Pat with
the ranking of Donald Trump's kids I
think Don juniors probably made like
third like if this happened to Ivanka
Trump investigation will be totally over
Ivanka would be pardoned if that ins a
baron which I don't foresee happening
maybe maybe trouble to get upset as well
but once you start getting down to
Donald Trump jr. - Eric the Tiffany
Trump maybe he doesn't care so much I
actually think the ranking for Trump
would be that Ivanka is his favorite
particularly you know all those times
he's talked about how amazing her body
is it seems he really really seems to
think of her as just the tops then I
would say it's Eric Trump then I would
say it's Don junior and then sort of at
the bottom
I think it's Tiffani and Baron who he
just doesn't even really seem to talk
about I am really thrilled to tell you
that one of today's sponsors is a
service that I personally use myself
called simple habit and you can get a
free trial at simple habit comm slash
Pakman it is really important to take a
break from Twitter to take a break from
the inundation of politics and media and
Trump and all of the stuff that's going
on and a really great way to take that
break and sort of do a mental reset is
with simple habit a guided meditation
app that just won the 2018 Google Play
award for best well-being app perfect
for people with busy lifestyles you just
need five minutes a day
they have morning meditations
meditations for going to sleep
meditations for dealing with headaches
stress meditations for athletes for
fighting procrastination for promoting
creativity they have a huge catalogue of
hundreds and hundreds of meditations for
almost anything you're trying to
accomplish and you can use the app to
track all of your progress they also
have music you can listen to that's
designed specifically to keep you calm
and focused while you're working or
reading go check it out you can try it
free for seven days at simple habit calm
slash Pakman I've put a link underneath